I never thought of myself as one of the
first wave of women much of my career I
thought it that I've sort of been
following in the women who went ahead of
me and blazing the trails that made it
possible to do what I've done and this
really is the first point in my life
where I've gotten to be the first woman
i think a lot of the reason it happened
has a lot to do with who Kellogg is has
a lot to do also with the state of where
business education has gotten to right
now women's students come up to me and
women from many different areas come up
and say how did you get to be Dean of
kellogg and I said well don't follow my
model was the wrong one right you know I
was a woman be I was a social
psychologist rather than economist and
see I just spent six years in
undergraduate business education and
none of those have tended to be the
power alleys and yet what I think it
tells us the fact that Kellogg is ready
to appoint a woman and a top business
school was is that the world has changed
a lot there's a much deeper appreciation
of psychology and business school
environments in addition to economics
you know that's something I knew was
important when I made the choice to
study psychology years ago but I think
the world has certainly embraced that
view more so
it's an interesting thing that when you
look at graduate schools of business
about thirty percent to thirty-five
percent of the students tend to be women
and this is true at else you know at all
top business schools through every sort
of sector of the business school
education domain whereas if you look at
law schools you look at medical schools
they tend to be about fifty percent
women and the feeder undergraduate
programs at colleges and research
universities are now most of them are at
least fifty percent women if not more
this persistent fact that business
schools are lower is an interesting
question and I people are just beginning
to get some data around it i recently
read a study done by the simmons college
and school of business and it's finding
there are negative attitudes towards
business of women in the high school in
the junior high school years and they
think that that may be in part
explaining why not as many women are
going to graduate schools of business i
still think it's a perplexing question
though because business is such a
dominant institution in our society and
so many people are drawn to it it's the
most popular undergraduate major in the
country so while i see the negative
business attitudes piece you know I keep
wondering is that the whole answer it's
important data it's the cheapest degree
it's only two years rather than three
four or five so it truly is a perplexing
question part of it I wonder is if we
haven't misrepresented in some ways what
you learn at business school to me the
greatest skill that you learn is how to
build effective organizations you learn
about the markets and how they work but
you learn how to build effective
organizations which is how we as human
beings organized which is how we get
things done and I think if we did a
better job at explaining to people that
that's what it's about I think that more
women might be drawn to it because women
naturally organized in their communities
and our families in our churches and you
know in all sorts of domains and I can't
help wondering if we need to get more
enlightened language so people truly
understand that business school really
is about building effective
organizations within a market context
but it can also be in a not-for-profit
context or religious context
I think it's just a question of time
quite honestly in terms of the unique
challenges to women we've broken the
glass ceilings now in many places not
maybe it has high numbers as some people
would have hoped but we've done it you
know it's interesting that we broke the
glass ceiling of Harvard before we did
have a major business school for example
right we've broken the glass ceilings at
a lot of fortune 500 companies I
recently had the privilege of being
asked to go to the fortune most powerful
women summit it was in Washington DC
this past fall and the room was just
packed with these incredibly talented
women and I looked around and I found
myself intimidated and I realized people
are intimidated by what I've done I mean
I think that we're doing it it's a
question of choices for women because it
does require trade-offs you don't get to
have it all you can't have a perfect
marriage perfect kids a perfect job and
be in perfect shape physically and I
think it's a question of trade-offs and
how far women decide to go in the into
business I think will impart to turn be
determined by choices about child
rearing and the structure of the
American family and how do we decide to
allocate our resources
economics is the study of markets and
most sociology also involves the study
of markets many disciplines take an eye
on them it's important to remember that
all a market is is a group of like
transactions and all a transaction is is
a buyer and seller getting together a
buyer saying I want that a seller saying
I don't want it as much as you want it
because the price you're willing to give
me is higher than the price that I that
I you know that I that I need to keep it
and that's the nature of human Commerce
going all the way back to the earliest
days of human organizing an
understanding that all a market is an
aggregation of people selling and buying
similar things and that our models of
markets are just that they're models
supply and demand don't exist they're a
model of what we see in everyday life
that help us understand everyday life
when we add your grade all those buyer
and seller transactions together and
helping students understand how human
society functions how it naturally self
organizes which is what a market is is
what a free market economy is because
even in the socialist economies and the
communists those markets existed they
may be work tracked officially but they
were there and they were operating and
so when I think about how we bring that
into education it's how do we help
students understand how humans organized
how humans interact and bring value to
each other I love Adam Smith calls it
about our propensity to truck now
obviously I never thought of that as a
verb and had meaning back then but I
love that phrase now our propensity to
truck is what makes us different from
the animals our propensity to engage in
transactions of me to sell you something
and you to buy it so that I don't you
know you'll do the farming and I'll do
the sewing and by having this propensity
to truck will each have more well-being
in our lives it's a very simple
principle and I sometimes think that
when we use words like markets and
networks things we create an abstraction
of reality these are models of how we
exist
because I look out at the world and I
see what creates wealth and business by
the way for me is organizations and
markets which are both important parts
of it and it's organizations offering it
aiding as actors in markets and I look
at it the world and I watch it's not the
government that's creating jobs it's not
the governance that's creating
innovation it's not the church that's
doing it it's not you know you can get
something done so much faster with a
for-profit business then you can with a
not-for-profit or a government or a
religious based business or even an NGO
and you can move jobs and move wealth
and solve problems so much faster it's
pretty obvious it's the dominant social
institution now do I like that every day
no because sometimes as it's become the
dominant social institution we've
allowed market-based logics to dominate
our thinking part of how did 2008
occurred how did all your classmates get
lured as you talked about to Wall Street
is because money has become even more
motivating to us in the age of the
business of the dominant social
institution and money is only a metric
money is only one place of value in life
and if there's a sort of a challenge
that we're going to have if we're going
to react Willa Breit it's going to be as
a human on a psyche level understanding
how much business has come to dominate
and homogenize and control culture in
some cases and making conscious
decisions about where we're going to let
that happen and where we're not right
now we're dealing with the unintended
consequences of business emerging as the
dominant social institution and we're
beginning to have dialogues about how do
we push that monetary metric back a
little to let other values on the table
as a society both nationally and
globally
markets aren't fair or unfair markets
create wealth and they're incredibly
efficient at allocating goods and
resources and creating surplus for
society that makes people better off but
markets have nothing to do with how that
well-being gets allocated across members
of society and you can't argue they're
fair or unfair they're agnostic there a
moral not immoral a moral it's we as
human beings to get to decide how much
each person should be entitled to on a
moral and values-based level and I
personally am somebody who believes the
fact that a billion out of the six
billion of us on the planet live on what
less than a dollar a day isn't fair and
I don't believe that markets can solve
it I do believe they can create more
wealth to spread to help solve it but if
we just allow markets unchecked and
somehow argue that will take care of it
I've seen no data to indicate that
markets will know because they aren't
knowing they're allocating their
generative not loving
clearly the service sector is where we
excel in the US economy versus the
manufacturing and so clearly that's
going to be in the knowledge base
sectors because that's where we have
still have a leg up in the world in
higher education and people who come out
with critical thinking skills so clearly
those pieces are going to lead finance
is already playing a bigger role than
any of us thought it would but I
personally in terms of sort of hopes and
dreams I think that social enterprise is
having more on a small scale but there's
more vigor in that than I would have
guessed five or ten years ago and that
excites me
for the foreseeable future the service
sector has eclipsed manufacturing and a
lot of it's a simple cost argument we
cannot manufacture as economically in
the United States as you can in
developing countries because all kinds
of tax reasons benefit reasons and
things that we require and are good for
society
the interesting thing about economics
and Marcus and the developing the
developed world is we've never played
out this game before at a global scale
we don't know if there is long-term harm
to losing a manufacturing base
intuitively it feels very uncomfortable
it's unclear where certain sectors of
our society are going to continue to
find employment when you drive through
Detroit it's absolutely scary in some
situations or cities like Buffalo that
used to have these manufacturing bases
so I would argue we don't know the
answer to that but I'm not sure we can
fix it right now until people are
willing to not look for the lowest cost
on certain manufactured goods the
developed world will win out or the
developing world as a job space for
manufacturing will win out over the
developed world and in order for that to
change we'd have to change how we buy
and how we consume and it's hard to
foresee in the near future how that's
going to change so in many ways I don't
know that we have a choice we have to
play it out and see what happens the
beautiful thing is the internet for
example we didn't even know about it 20
years ago and even 15 nobody thought it
was going to circle the globe as fast as
it did there's so many no and that's
where you get your hope and sense of
surprise is there may well be things
that are going to happen that we can't
even imagine that make this service
dominated developed economy just falling
and what we have to do and I get back to
education is keep educating the thinkers
and the innovators and the critique errs
who will help those breakthroughs come
to bear because that's the only hope for
human society because at some point the
developing world will have played out
this chain as well and we will have
robots manufacturing everything basic
and the question is what is human life
then what is the marketplace then how do
we find meaning and value and get our
needs met and feed our families
you